[Music]
what's up guys
helen here and today we're going to talk
about a topic that single-handedly
raised america's blood pressure 50
millimeters
which is a lot that's right cancel
culture now
clearly the term is getting its fair
share of media attention cancel culture
cancel culture cancel culture
cancel culture cancel culture but what
does it really mean
according to our friend miriam it's the
practice or tendency of engaging in mass
cancelling
as a way of expressing disapproval and
exerting social pressure
in this context to cancel means to
withdraw one's support for someone such
as a celebrity or something such as a
company
publicly and especially on social media
simple enough right
not so much cancel culture has turned
into something of a catch-all phrase for
the social repercussions for everything
from bad jokes
to workplace harassment to really effing
stupid tweets
and a lot of people are super angry
about it arguing that the threat of
being canceled is hurting free speech
hurting public discourse and most
tragically hurting tucker carlson's
feelings
but the more interesting question to us
is what is cancelled culture actually
doing
specifically is it actually righting
wrongs when somebody gets cancelled for
doing or saying
something bad has justice been served so
let's be brave and try to figure it out
in this wisecrack edition on cancel
culture
but before we get into it here's a super
casual plea
if you dig our channel why not check out
our podcast
as we like to say they're really just
youtube videos for your ears
so go get your audio content game on
with one or all three of our sublime
pods there's show me the meaning where
host austin ryan and raymond comb
through your favorite movies in search
of as advertised the
seriously deep meaning or there's
culture binge where we explore the most
urgent
fascinating and deranged things going on
in the cultural zeitgeist with hosts
michael and serbi and special guests
like yours truly and if you stan dan
harmon you gotta check out the squanch
where hosts michael ryan and friends
overanalyze every new rick and morty
episode until their brains break into
the fourth dimension
you can listen to our shows on apple
podcasts spotify stitcher or wherever
the heck you get your podcast these days
you can
also catch the live streams of each
podcast here on the wisecrack channel so
make sure you got your notifications on
and if you ever do miss an episode you
can always watch the recorded streams
over at our wisecast channel so why
haven't you subscribed yet
seriously just do it and now back to the
show
now the primary function of any given
cancellation is to publicly shame the
person in question for
some kind of technically speaking a
recent high profile example is chrissy
teigen
model turned social media personality
and multi-hyphenate here's the skinny
courtney stodden a model most famous for
marrying their abusive 51 year old agent
at the age of 16
spoke out about the horrific bullying
they endured in the spotlight
they specifically named tegan who
repeatedly tweeted and messaged cruel
things to stodden but it's so
damaging when you have somebody
like chrissy teigen bullying children
most egregiously by encouraging them to
commit suicide
something to the high school student
legit went to jail for a few years ago
after this revelation other instances of
tegan's public and private online
bullying were brought to the internet's
attention
outrage quickly ensued perhaps in part
because tegan built a whole brand on the
strength of her spunky charisma and
clapbacky persona and has previously
spoken out about her own experiences
being bullied
tegan was subsequently dropped from a
netflix show lost most of her business
affiliations and relinquished her status
as twitter darling
the internet pylon predictably dominated
social media for days
and tegan went offline to reflect on her
misdeeds
as has become typical for a cancelee she
returned a month later with an online
apology that
predictably seemed to provoke more anger
in it she apologizes for causing harm by
being a self-proclaimed
troll and reflects on what it's like to
be publicly shamed for being a massive
[ __ ]
only to return to instagram later to
lament her status as part of the
canceled club and so
the saga continues while a tegan style
public shaming wasn't possible until
digital hell on earth was invented in
2009
america is no stranger to public shaming
for various infractions
as journalist john ronson recounts in
his book so you've been publicly shamed
he notes that dating back to our puritan
forefathers our country has a
delightfully sadistic history of using
public punishment like stocks and
whippings for crimes as small as
adultery
blasphemy and our favorite erecting a
maypole
when it wasn't may day it's like getting
the death penalty for leaving your
christmas tree up in january
eventually public shaming tight
punishments mostly disappeared because
the practices were deemed too brutal
prison or of course the death penalty
became more prominent
because you know prison or death is
better than being humiliated in front of
your neighbors
but in recent years ronson argues public
shaming has returned with the force not
seen since colonial times
with the interconnectedness of the
internet once private infractions like
bullying or hate speech can become
instantly public
but instead of being shamed by your
small town you're shamed by the whole
freaking world
now obviously chrissy teigen
experiencing a twitter takedown is not
equivalent to a puritan woman being
whipped for coveting her neighbor's
boner however
both are excellent examples of something
called retributive justice
in his defense of it legal scholar
joseph wyler explains that retributive
justice is based on society's desire to
mete out deserved punishment for the
commission of offenses against laws
which define and protect the freedom of
its members
that is to say retributive justice is
primarily concerned with punishing
somebody proportionately to the harm
they caused
under the theory of retributive justice
it is even morally good to give an
offender their just deserts
retributive justice dates all the way
back to the ancient babylonian code of
hammurabi and appears in the bible in
that classic line an eye for an eye
a tooth for a tooth and philosophers
like immanuel kant
stand state imposed retributive justice
arguing that under proportionate
punishment
a thief must be punished by not being
allowed to own any property while a
murderer must be punished by death
this sounds suspiciously in line with
tegan's punishment
she sent super mean tweets and now she's
on the receiving end of super mean
tweets
but is justice really being served when
people tell chrissy teigen to take a
dirt nap
a lot of thinkers would say no and for a
number of reasons
a common critique when all the focus is
on punishing the perpetrator we kind of
conveniently forget about the victim who
endured the harm in the first place
that is in our gusto to get back the bad
guy we rarely consider how the victim is
doing
i.e is anyone who's lashing out at tegan
really thinking about stauden's feelings
what's more retributive justice has
almost no concern with facilitating
accountability
that is with having the perpetrator take
responsibility for their actions
offer an explanation for their mistake
and promise to you know
do better in fact when internet
cancelees do ostensibly attempt to take
responsibility
it's typically and maybe fairly
dismissed as a cynical pr stunt
in the retributive justice of cancelled
culture our focus is pretty much
all in the punishment whether it's
getting someone fired or just getting
them to really super hate themselves
but what's the alternative to
straight-up punishment america is a
country pretty preoccupied with all
things punitive i mean we have a chill
6.7 million people in the criminal
justice system including parole for
god's sake
so it's not surprising that we seem
constitutionally incapable of finding an
alternative way to dole out justice
but what if there was a way to enact
justice that was less obsessed with an
eye for an eye
and more interested in say minimizing
pain at large
improving society and most of all
helping victims move on from the traumas
they've endured
sound too good to be true enter
restorative justice
a system of accountability focused on
doing just that
as one of the modern movements founders
howard zaire puts it
restorative justice provides an
alternative framework for thinking about
wrongdoing
it's less concerned with punishment than
with considering the needs and roles of
all parties involved the start of any
attempt at restorative justice considers
the victim
in this case stodden and others and
assesses the harm they endured because
of tegan's actions
it then asks how can we make things
whole retributive justice promises to do
so by doling out punishments
but is it functionally making things
right proponents of restorative justice
would probably say
nah importantly restorative justice
distinguishes between the idea of
punishment and consequences
that is between forcing the perpetrator
to suffer and
forcing the perpetrator to face up to
what they did and try to make things
right
in this way it centers responsibility
accountability
and the wrongdoer's obligations to their
community in healing the harm done
so in the case of chrissy teigen the
question would be less how do we make
tegan suffer
and more how do we make things right by
stodden and facilitate their recovery
from this painful period of their life
to that end restorative justice often
includes a face-to-face meeting between
victim and offender who were often
joined by family or community members
at these meetings the victim is given
time to ask questions and to state the
harms inflicted
it's also an opportunity for the
perpetrator to take responsibility and
give an apology
from there the offender is often
assigned specific obligations tailored
to their case
sometimes centered around changing their
behavior or performing community service
or a host of other options
the goal of restorative justice is to
eventually re-integrate the victim
and the offender back into their
community these meetings often end with
amends and closure
restorative justice in its modern
iteration draws inspiration from
indigenous communities especially those
from north america and new zealand
including navajo peacemaking courts such
a model has
since 1989 been the primary way that new
zealand treats juvenile criminal
offenders
and has resulted in a 15 reduction in
those offenders committing future crimes
of course with cancelled culture we're
not dealing with a criminal justice
system
and we admit we had trouble imagining
what restorative justice really looks
like in the context of internet cancel
culture after all going to twitter for
nuanced discourse is like going to hot
topic for an elegant wedding dress
what's more attempts at online
restorative justice could easily turn
into performative grandstanding devoid
of any actual depth the exact kind of
thing tegan was roasted for in her
apology post
but author and activist adrian marie
brown has some ideas as outlined in her
recent booklet we will not cancel us
in which she asks can we release our
binary ways of thinking of good and bad
in order to collectively grow from
mistakes while she's specifically
discussing the rise of cancellations in
activist groups
we think her arguments can be applied to
society at large
brown notes the disturbing way cancel
culture resembles a feeding frenzy among
sharks
she writes we are full of justified rage
and we want to release that rage
and one really fast and easy way to do
this is what i experience
as a knee-jerk collective punishment i.e
retributive justice that's all about
causing pain
rather than righting wrongs she asks why
does it feel like we are committed to
punishment and enjoying it
that is to say are we just puritans with
smartphones
see call out culture can be immensely
satisfying to our lizard brains
when we paint someone like tegan as bad
and beyond redemption
it makes us feel better about ourselves
what's more
it can even feel productive when we
declare tegan no longer worthy of a
public platform and expunge her from our
culture
it can feel like we're cleansing society
of a major ill but
are we according to brown cancer culture
is predicated on the assumption that
problems like violence and
sexism and racism stem from individual
violent people or sexist or racists
she argues that more accurately these
social ills come from
society at large the oppressive
instincts are baked into our larger
communities
rather than resulting from individual
bad apples that is to say
when someone does or says something
racist on twitter.com
it's not like they made up racism in a
vacuum don't get us wrong personal
responsibility
absolutely plays a role but these types
of tweets are
also symptomatic of the racism that
permeates our entire society
and has ever since columbus got lost and
showed up uninvited on our shores
following this train of thought brown
explains we won't end the systemic
patterns of harm by isolating and
picking off individuals
given this reality she explains
cancelling someone for saying something
racist
doesn't solve racism and if anything can
distract from the huge structural issues
that make people think and say
racist things in the first place as she
writes we are all connected to each
other at our best
and our worst in the case of tegan it's
worth noting that
while what she did and said was horrible
she was merely one voice in the
collective bandwagon roasting courtney
stodden
then a literal child the media treated
soden horrifically
mocking and deriding them mercilessly
which by their own account only
compounded the trauma they experienced
in their abusive relationship
while canceling tegan can feel
satisfying it doesn't begin to make up
for the way society collectively hurts
stodden
again instead of centering stodden's
pain we are going ham on tegan's
punishment
in this vein brown takes restorative
justice a step further
she argues that restoring things to the
flawed way they were before
isn't enough we need to transform them
via what she and others call
transformative justice now if you're
thinking all this sounds a bit woo-woo
it's worth looking at how restorative
justice actually functions in criminal
justice systems
the results can be inspiring consider
one new zealand defender who burglarized
two houses and made amends with his
victims through a group conference
did community service and earned back
the money he stole by saving 50
a week the victims were so impressed by
his dedication that they told him to
keep the money for his new baby rather
than return it
similar results and similar closure have
even occurred in cases of murder
where victims families have actually
befriended the perpetrator after
restorative justice efforts brought them
together
of course there's no criminal justice
system on twitter but there are examples
of a restorative justice model working
online
and one has to do with your favorite tv
creator dan harmon who was accused in
2018 of making inappropriate advances
toward an employee
megan gantz and eventually firing her
after she rejected him
after she spoke out about the injustice
harmon took full accountability
started a dialogue with her apologized
and made public statements about his
wrongdoings
gans subsequently forgave him rather
than simply using the opportunity to
cancel him
and harmon genuinely used the
opportunity to learn grow
and promise to do better harmon and
writer jessica gao even started a
podcast dedicated to exploring racism
and sexism in the comedy writing world
so hey progress while this is a good
example
it required the willingness of all
parties involved the person accused of
wrongdoing to step up and take
accountability
the victim to be willing to listen and
the internet collectively being willing
to give harman another shot
which definitely had nothing to do with
the fact that he's responsible for some
of the best television of our time
so is there a world where what happened
with dan harmon could happen with
chrissy teigen
maybe but we're not gonna bet on it it
seems for restorative justice to
regularly work in the digital world
it would practically require everyone on
the internet to magically agree
which yeah we don't see that happening
but what we do think is that the
mechanisms of cancel culture in the case
of folks like tegan
may stem from good intentions to hold
people accountable but don't generally
create positive change or make us better
because it's too
focused on punishing individuals rather
than transforming
systemic problems but what do you guys
think
is canceled culture productive can
restorative or transformative justice
ever work for internet offences are we
cancelled for making this video
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for all your support
smash that subscribe button like you're
dismantling oppressive systems instead
of canceling individuals
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
bye